When you're different,
you have to work
at belonging.
Everybody wants
to feel valued
and accepted,
and we think it should
happen spontaneously,
but it doesn't.
Sometimes,
society tells us,
and we tell ourselves,
we don't fit the mold.
Take a piece of paper,
and write down what
makes you different,
and I want you to
celebrate it
today and every day,
shout it from
the rooftops.
What makes
me different
is what has made
me stand out
and be successful.
I also encourage you to
be curious and ask,
"What is on other people's
pieces of paper?"
"What makes them
different?"
Let's celebrate those
imperfections
that make us special.
I hope that it
teaches you
that nobody has a claim
on the word "normal."
We are all different.
We are all quirky,
and unique,
and that is what
makes us
wonderfully human.